(playful music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(children laughing)
(upbeat piano music)
- [Narrator] In the town of Adipur
in India's Gujarat state,
you will find a man
who is arguably Charlie
Chaplin's biggest fan.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Dr. Aswani
practices herbal medicine
in his village and uses Charlie Chaplin
to help treat his patients.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Dr. Aswani isn't the only one
with a passion for Mr. Chaplin.
He started the Charlie
Circle in 1973 to honor
and remember one of the
world's greatest comedians.
Charlie Chaplin is beloved
because of his every man attitude
and comedy that brought joy to the masses.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Every year the Charlie Circle
celebrates Charlie Chaplin with a parade,
singing, dancing and, of course, cake.
(group cheering)
(upbeat orchestral music)
(audience laughing)
(audience applauds)
(bright electronic tone dings)